هذه الكارثه الكبيره لكن ما زال هناك امل
رغم التضاؤل ايضا فرص النجاه لكن عمال
الانقاذ يقولون انهم ربما
يعثرون على شخص اخر ما زال يقاوم تحت
الانقاض لذلك العمليات تستمر طبعا في هذا
الموقع في مدينه اصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب
فرق الانقاذ الان هناك تبديل للورديات
هناك
اعاده شحن للمولدات الكهربائيه لاستئناف
العمل في هذا الموقع
المدمر بالكامل هذا الموقع كما تشاهدون
هنا هو او هذا البناء هو جزء تقريبا من
حيث انهار بالكامل كنا في النشره الماضيه
في حي اخر كان منهارا بشكل كبير او بشكل
كامل لا يوجد اي بناء على بقيه
بقي واقفا هذا الحي هناك مبنى او اثنين او
ثلاثه مباني فقط
كلمه لكن هناك تشققات وتصدعات في هذه
المباني لذلك كما نشاهد هنا هذا الركام
تحت هذا الركام ما زالت فرق الانقاذ تحاول
الوصول الى
الى ناجين الان خلال دقائق قليله سيستانف
العمل في هذا الموقع بعد ان توقف لي وقت
قصير جدا كما ذكرنا
اولا تبديل الورديات وايضا موضوع شحن
المولدات
جلب معدات جديده واستئناف العمل من جديد
في هذه المدينه المنكوبه حقيقه
يعني نحن نتحدث عن مدينه اصلاحيه هذه
المدينه اكثر من 50% من مبانيها انهارت
بشكل كامل وهناك 30% من القسم المتبقي من
المباني متصدعا وغير صالح للسكن لذلك
نتحدث عن مدينه منكوبه بنسبه تتراوح ما
بين 70 الى 80% وبالتالي بحاجه بح الى
اعاده اعمار تقريبا كل المباني وكل البنى
التحتيه حتى الطرق حقيقه التي توصل الى
اصلاحيه
سيئه جدا هناك تصدعات وتشققات كبيره في
الطرق بعض الطرق هناك حفر في بعض الطرق
وصلت الى نصف متر يعني وهذا معاناه اضافيه
اولا في وصول المساعدات بشكل سلس وعدم
تشكل
ازدحامات على الطرق الواصله الى هذه
المدينه ايضا هناك مدينه مجاوره لاصلاحيه
قريبه عليها قريبه جدا من اصلاحها ايضا
تقريبا هناك المدينه
دمر قسم كبير منها وبالتالي عمليات
الاغاثه وارسال المساعدات الى هاتين
المدينتين مستمره وبوتيره عاليه لكن حقيقه
حجم الضرر كبير جدا في هاتين المدينتين
هناك الاف الاشخاص
في الخيام التي وفرتها لهم هناك ايضا
اشخاص حتى الان لم تصلهم خيام التقيناهم
يوم امس هنا في احدى المناطق القريبه من
اصلاحها لم يستطيعوا الحصول على خيم تخيلي
الحراره الان
4 درجات تحت الصفر واشخاص يعيشون بخيم
بدائيه محترئه ولديهم اطفال وهناك نساء
وايضا